the war in ukraine comes with a horrific
toll on the people involved emotional
and financial it's costing russia an
estimated 20 million dollars a day to
continue the invasion the ukrainian
government hasn't put a price tag on its
defenses but it's issued war bonds to
raise funds received millions in
donations from allies and turned to less
conventional methods on saturday
ukraine's vice prime minister tweeted a
request for donations in the world's
largest cryptocurrencies
more than 69 million dollars of crypto
has poured in from around the world for
the ukrainian government and ngos this
is actually a pretty good solution
because it is something that the
russians cannot steal finance professor
andreas park says even if russia gains
control of ukrainian banks crypto
remains safe but unreliable internet
complicates things though elon musk the
world's richest man has activated his
company's satellite internet service in
ukraine in a bid to help
crypto funds are also being sent to
russian citizens in the midst of a
spiraling recession unable to use credit
cards with limited access to cash and
authorities are on alert because
vladimir putin and russian oligarchs may
funnel assets into crypto to lessen the
blow of sanctions targeting their
businesses and prized possessions but
blockchain experts say bitcoin isn't
liquid enough or deep enough to make a
real dent but if we're looking at the
order of magnitude that you need in
order to meaningfully circumvent
sanctions the cryptocurrency world is
just not ready for that and it's
traceable
much like the so-called freedom convoy
in canada tech ceo brian masoff says
crypto is proving to be a big part of
this international story too this is a
tool that's going to be used for things
you support things that you may be
against but that the technology itself
is politically neutral
cryptocurrency has emerged as a
technological double-edged sword with
the potential to help a movement that's
captured the zeitgeist outweighing its
potential to limit sanctions ann gaviola
global news toronto